welcome to this video playing Hagen hi I
no no I shouldn't try that even I just
should keep with my my bad pronunciation
and and okay I have 15 games against the
sky with the track record of 12 wins and
3 losses no draw that's not bad and no
drawers honey at 15 games and this looks
like a time when I have to wait five
minutes and went on time OS is one of
those pizza guy at the door games okay
it's moving so hmm yeah the French I'm
obviously not an expert at this one p 6
i'm a teammate of mine sometimes played
that in the dutch league i know that
there's an old game of tau where tau
played queen f3 and this is supposed to
be dangerous okay it's black threatening
to take him maybe okay i'm trying to to
play aggressively him if he takes it and
just making a gambit out of it okay so i
get in long castles very quickly mmm how
do i go there may be here yeah and
checking on g7 that could be an idea and
also bishop c7 this kind of moves look
look very dangerous why come on no this
is not working for black don't give me
that Bishop to b6 Knight f6
maybe this is just about working because
of 97 I have Bishop c7 though Bishop c7
Quincy eight and then Bishop b5 he has
to play f6 hmm now come on stead start
with this is probably right in any case
and think about this i also have night d
6 which looks looks great as well or
Bishop b5 as mentioned Bishop f5 f6
should be 5f six hmm then 96 maybe i'm
not sure but okay if I spent three
minutes see I'm going to lose on time so
going to delay that yeah it looks it
looks dreadful but maybe we can can
somehow hang on like 97 lat h6 intending
night at five but our game it must be
very good forward
maybe night night h3 to f4 this could be
a good plan maybe yeah I was thinking
about this move may be a knight f5 p.m.
there's no way really to prevent that
probably
all rookie one maybe rookie one let's
start with that a successor yeah now I
have Queen h3 maybe and then King g7 now
I don't like come on let's that's
develop right at five queen age three is
good anyway I take h7 if he takes the 60
I just need more more firepower am King
geez have enough late Bishop f4 back and
then g4 maybe c5 now it's still g4 now
this this is this the name I cannot
believe that black and survived that but
I definitely I probably have not found
them the most convincing reputation see
file if looks like the only move though
everything else should should probably
lose out right
c5 we can I go g4g form must be the
right move really removing the only
defender I'm a bit puzzled okay this one
the puzzle that he was taking so long
but I thought that c5 was really the
only way to to put up any resistance now
the gphi look sir looks very deadly just
look lucre g1 basically yeah I take here
but winning material yeah it's it's
close I can't play rookie six though i
know i can i can fly anything i can i
can really take just here rook takes
Queen at fire that's pretty pretty good
rook takes I can even take michelle b 6i
will think in Queen at five but there
should be six will also win when Queen
g6 comes back let's think about it for
just a moment but it's yes enough no
need to to look for two wins I have
rookie one at the end check picking up
the Queen
check
check check this should really somehow
winders now that's totally uncoordinated
blacks camp check how do we know may
come on let's just push the edge porn
like has no move anyway it really has
some kinky aid or whatever everything's
tied together
I could have played neither my back
she's a butt black has no move in any
case this was an opening an opening
disaster in a way yeah there'd be six is
a questionable line as as far as i know
i'm not sure this was this is as a
famous star game where Todd one very
quickly with that but I'm not sure about
the objective merit c6 yeah I don't know
this this looks very risky other comp
actually says white wins so okay cannot
cannot do something like this I mean as
suspected that much but okay here we
ship here and now we have white asses
home already winning according to the
computer yeah black irony has no moves
King f8 seems to be the toughest but he
went g6 relatively quickly yeah and now
it's a matter of how to how to how to
win this up the compass giving an even
stronger line at this one here f6 I was
thinking that maybe this is possible but
this is a very simple reputation like
I'm sorry here f6 and now Bishop c4 is
very strong yeah that's um if you if you
look at this I mean what what what kind
of position is that black is getting
getting like it's it on the ad with a
crowbar physically impossible okay so I
went I went with this which is probably
check yeah it's just a plus plus three
position so it's it's it's enough okay
oh this should should be somehow all
right yeah and here i was surprised i
think he really should play c5 and this
is also giving us the only move by the
comp I wasn't totally sure I was
thinking that probably g4 should be
right being the most forceful move but I
wasn't sure g-form let's let's check
this know the comps s white winter okay
so I had the right hunch them however
after night takes I I was thinking that
I should some more have queen age 60
should be good but g5 is the computer
suggestion with a win that's cute really
something like this check okay terrible
and this after g4s and plus 8 the
multiple multiple wins this is this is
enough though Queen f5 also hunters
winner probably I probably missed some
sort of checkmate yeah 95 is a maid in
fact made in 6 according to stock fish
okay but I winning the greenness is
perfectly okay this is probably a very
questionable opening line okay thanks
for watching